the goal is to get to 10 billion the  mission is to just make real business  knowledge available for everyone  everything I do at large that's why I  make the books so I make the courses  that's why we do the YouTube stuff  that's why we make the shorts I do  believe that I'll gain more perspective  as things grow so it's more than I'm  just curious what I'm going to learn  going from 200 million dollar your  portfolio to a 10 billion dollar your  portfolio my goal is to just document  the path when I die hopefully there'll  just be a whole bunch of people who are  younger than me who make way more money  than I do at my age because they were  able to just shortcut a lot